pense vraiment que ça nous ferait du
bien ti week-end au bord des larmes et
un bébé chez nous à l'abbé deschamps
ça fait six mois qu'on m'appelle comme
ça je suis débile aussi mais je vous
disais le début c'est trop tard je suis
condamné map les bébés chats pour
l'éternité mais béja oui mes bébés chats
try to wed en déraison séguin au débotté
aucune fouille pas d'accord avec un
grand oui c'est une très bonne idée
véracité toujours motivé dans cinq
minutes quand je te rennes on sait que
doit durer toute façon c'est forcément
des loups à alléger étudier toutes les
solutions je lui dis maintenant qu'est
ce que t'es tu tu dis rien alors je
réfléchis j'ai toujours dit qu'il
fallait séparer amour et boulot le
savait mais rld avait qu'à pas sortir
avec moi quoi c'est moi la victime dans
cette histoire
quoi tu penses à laisser le monde de
l'entreprise
je le fais pour la boîte c'est normal de
faire un travail on vire les gens qu'on
aime c'est vrai quoi c'est normal c'est
normal j'accepte cette idée j'accepte ce
monde tard est allé d'un coup sec comme
un pansement alice on va s'arrêter là
quand j'ai tout essayé j'ai tout essayé
je comprends pas parce qu'un fou - tout
cas ça se passe très bien de moi le sel
c'était peut-être rien à voir ce n'est
pas du tout en cause là dedans là c'est
moi c'est nous saisissent s'est
définitivement oui mais je vais t'aider
à trouver je comprends pas en fait je
viens ici je te parle de week-end
tumulty tu me dis oui de béchar aux
parents semblent machin est juste après
tu me dis ça j'ai l'impression d'avoir
affaire à un malade un bipolaire temps
avant le week-end je suis à fond ma
gueule mais je comprends pas là tu me
tues me dis que tu m'aimes je dit une
petite commune gilbert comme ça la clé
du vitré tuvalu cette date elle croit
que la quitte
ah non non non non mais attends attends
attends alice dona n'a rien à voir
attends attends attends c'est un peu
j'en profite pour la quitter aussi parmi
ces locations à temps vers été plus
simple comme ça j'aurais pas assumer
mais ce que j'aime vraiment d'ailleurs
jo peut-être pas tant de choses que ça
en commun elles méritent des fois même
pour tout le monde mérite pas une raison
suffisante alors qua non mais tonton du
tout le monde est cher attend peut-être
plus simple
je vous dis au revoir à dieu je
m'en va vers les cieux plus cléments
dans une boîte prestigieuse pour un
meilleur poste et un plus gros salaire
stagner titre quoi tu parles
bah oui je vous le dis donc t'as pu
besoin de vie de deux virées personnes
banon sept ans un champion à temps alors
madame alice alors
c'était en train de gérer quoi était en
train de virer non j'avais pourquoi elle
elle est super rallye on avait dit que
c'était un des quatre ils devaient
partir ou tout au moins
ok bon écoutez bonbonnes bon beaucoup
ratio 1 et puis à bientôt
1 on sait jamais ça lui tente en
attendant de temps en temps à 17 h salle
celle ci s attend à temps se plaît à
temps à coacher je ne sais pas quoi dire
il ya diagne philippe jeanneret j'arrive
plus à penser il ya pas évident il ya il
a rien été tellement lâche je t'explique
tu vas rire voilà il y avait un poste à
supprimer dans le service c'était toi ou
moi
voilà donc moi j'ai pensé que tu m'aimes
aussi super six adorables
merci bébé chat alicia ou yahoo
puis ce que
[Musique]